[Music]
hello
you guys it's sunday sorry we're very
very tired
damn damn i know last night was
something else
we need to get back to like it was i
think it would solve us for in the
morning
i didn't realize like we stayed we
actually went to mannequins which uh
you know that's that's a lot easier
thing to do because it's like much much
closer
to our house and uh so we were there
until really late and then we're like
hey let's go over to
chantal's and get some she got some
catfish
yeah so we went over there when all the
friends showed up
with some of our friends and like then
like the people that were working there
were doing karaoke
and like before we knew it like we were
in there like eating and watching a baby
karaoke it was like [ __ ] hilarious they
had the waitress that worked there you
know
a girl from damn massachusetts who just
moved here
she did a great uh journey cover don't
stop
[Laughter]
and she's probably maybe like 20 years
old yeah
and we're like how do you know that song
right i was making fun
how
[Laughter]
yeah it was a good time but yeah so i
didn't realize we were in there that
long and then when we came out like
onto the streets of downtown sanford
there was nobody yeah we're like what
the [ __ ] and i was like and then i
looked at my thing i'm like oh it's
almost four in the morning that's why
like all the bars are closed there was
some dude holding his girlfriend over
the damn
iron grill and she was sucking yeah it
was where we were
about sex was happening that she was
throwing up she was throwing up
down in the corner he had her by the
back of the hair when i was like that
i forgot i remember that [ __ ] and
[ __ ] all the friends around there
watching it throw up
and i said jenny hold on get your camera
and they all started laughing even the
girl throwing up
started laughing yeah everyone was kind
of in a good food lesson
jenny get the camera she started
at least she was i mean at least she had
the presence of mine to throw up into
in the grill in the into the grape there
yeah i mean you know
i don't know if i would have had the
presence of mine didn't do that
no you don't you just go through it
wherever you are
[Laughter]
i'm like open the door she's in the car
throwing up in the damn
well because it's been real well said no
open the door
it's because i'm always trying to like
not throw up because i hate throwing up
yeah you're trying so i'm always trying
not to and then like
so i end up being like a damn [ __ ]
hose the whole car out
yeah i remember that remember that i
mean that was my old car i think yeah
that was my i think that was my other
car
yeah the one that wrecked blast all
everything out of there and then just go
in there and hand wash
everything with looking dish it was was
no no it was laundry detergent the
liquid laundry detergent i mean at least
i only threw up like
juice and boom yeah yeah it wasn't food
or anything
it's just all fluid yeah i think i
barfed on the side of the car one time
and i drunk like a bunch of vodka and
cranberry and then when i came back out
i was like oh my god i'm throwing up
blood and then i was like oh yeah it was
cranberry yeah
cranberry juice all right so i'm stupid
everybody's here louie's in here
everybody's hair hey yeah and it's
easter today i didn't even remember
it was because was he grilling her yeah
but actually for a second i thought it
was some some of that damn
viral homemade porn going on at first
but she was bent over right in front of
me well because nobody else was around
so it would be a good time to shoot it
yeah but then like the friends were
watching
yeah because it was it's like a ghost
town that had friends but then i
realized she was throwing up yeah
because it would be very uncommon to see
some [ __ ] like that in florida
yeah this is the land of this that kind
of thing you would just like walk by and
go
i suppose so yeah all right making money
i got you making money at least he's not
[Laughter]
like i said i didn't realize that we'd
been in the restaurant that long because
i think that's the only restaurant that
stays open
yeah like all night long unless they
were just waiting for us to leave
something
close but it was like four in the
morning so you know
yeah so i'm like really really tired
i've had like one big cup of coffee but
it doesn't really seem to be doing jack
all right so uh we're gonna be talking
today
about creep show yeah now i had totally
forgotten
like a dumbass that shutter puts
the um episodes of creep show up
one every week they don't put them all
up at once because they kind of want to
they don't they don't like doing that
bingy thing so it's just kind of like
they want it to be like
appointment tv like so when you put a
new one up like everybody just goes and
talks about that one
and you can concentrate on that one
which in a way is kind of like a cool
thing so so when we went to watch it i
was like was there only one episode then
i was like oh no
okay so uh yeah this is season two
episode one and it has two stories on it
and both of them i really really like
that they opened
the second season with two that are kind
of like
throwbacks to something else you know
what i'm saying
yeah um so you have like the first story
which is called model kid
and it was kind of like um
an homage to the original creepshow
movie
from the 80s the wraparound story you
know what i mean like with the kid with
the voodoo doll and
you know [ __ ] like that because his dad
was all like oh that horror crap and a
lot of that kind of stuff
so it was like an homage to that and
then the second story
which i think was called uh what was it
called public television of the dead or
something like that
and that was um a straight up homage to
evil dead
and it's delightful it was like an evil
dead episode it kind of was
yeah had even had a necronomicon in it
oh my god so funny both of them were
actually really really good i think that
these two stories were probably i mean
easily among my
favorites of all of them yeah i would i
have to say that this new creep show
series i think it's getting better as it
goes yeah
it definitely does seem to be getting
better i mean it was good when it
started
but it's getting better when it goes as
it goes i think yeah
because i guess that okay so this season
got delayed
because of the pandemic and everything
but remember they did like those couple
standalone ones they did the one
animated one that had survivor type
and a couple other stories on it oh okay
ghost pen and uh and then they had the
one i think it was like a christmas
special with all the santas or whatever
what that that was creep show right
yeah yeah yeah they did like a christmas
special that was not animated
but the other i liked the animated one
though um but this one
so so they're finally like you know
going back to it so like i said the
first one's called model kid
and it's about this little kid named joe
which like i said is funny because in
the movie creep show from the 80s
the little boy that was in the wrap
around that you know was like
with the voodoo doll that was stephen
king's son
joe who is now a novelist joe hill uh so
yeah so they named this kid joe
and he uh is a real he's super into
monster movies it's set in 1972.
i think i read some reviews of it and i
don't think people realize that it was
supposed to be set in 1972 even though
it said right on the [ __ ]
and it was it was obvious by the clothes
and the cars
yeah and the and the i don't know what
house you're living in but
they don't yeah it's like making avocado
[ __ ] refrigerators anymore
avocado that [ __ ] crappy avocado
colored [ __ ]
countertops and cooking [ __ ] i'm not
sure that was in there well like i said
everything was
avocado golden rod or like brown yeah or
burnt orange yeah that was a big color
wood paneling not sheetrock but wood
paneling
yeah and it wasn't even wood it was just
kind of like this pressed plastic yeah
it was fake wood yeah well it was classy
as [ __ ] man
they thought it was it looked like [ __ ]
it didn't age well either yeah it really
didn't yeah it's funny it's like a house
that i've
bought a long time ago in daytona had
that in the they had they had made the
garage
into like a den and they put [ __ ]
they both [ __ ] would that shitty wood
paneling all over it
and i was like i couldn't really afford
to have it all torn down so i just
painted over it yeah
i mean it looked fine i painted it blue
[ __ ] was paper thin yeah
you could hear through all the walls
yeah we tried you couldn't get away with
anything
yeah what are you doing in there all
right be quiet
telling your ex your girlfriend to be
quiet
they'll hear us stop all that screaming
yeah
oh my god you could hear that [ __ ]
hitting ass
through the wall man yeah oh what the
hell
memories yeah yeah okay so
i'm taking it down another direction
hormones [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh my god can we just talk a little bit
lat because last night oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah i posted a picture
of that
of what oh i didn't read it yeah oh yeah
yeah okay
yeah demetrius i'm gonna have to show
this picture you're gonna have children
you're gonna find it okay i'm good so
yeah so the first one there's a little
kid named joe
and he's super into monsters he's got
like all the models and he's got you
know he just loves
monster movies and he has even has like
a little um thank you ken
because i've missed you guys yeah he's
because of his work schedule he hasn't
been able to be here for the live ones
you know she had a picture yeah okay
all right this was this was
this was last night this is the two gens
all right
let me get get the camera i can't really
see
all right yes danny and jen i have one
of my fantastic wigs on yeah
and look at that oh man oh man
so yeah that's jen draven from
uh who she's a friend of ours she's her
husband they're over here all the time
we've done little photo shoots and [ __ ]
with them she's in the
13th angel yes and a band called 13th
angel and
she's one of the bet one of the
vocalists in it yeah she does all those
operatic type vocals
and she plays keyboards as well yeah and
looking they were sitting next to each
other and i was just like the [ __ ]
that trt was [ __ ] with me
i was seeing this she's like sit closer
together i was yeah
hold hands
[Laughter]
it was [ __ ] getting me and i kept
saying a gentleman like you see what i
have to deal with
yeah it's just [ __ ] and right above them
was the dj
booth and [ __ ] jen's husband's in
there dmitri he's he's [ __ ] spinning
and
there's a little crack in between the
little plastic and i'm going dude man
it's like it was back in that night in a
hotel room then
the abominable snowman is coming out
yeah
i'm seeing this [ __ ] it says i said look
at him she goes i know they're gorgeous
oh there's a look
there's a dude i got these tea goggles
on though i'm like
seeing it through the eyes of two 15
year olds right now and he's like oh it
must be intense
dude man what the [ __ ]
so i couldn't get that out of my mind
she was there i was open about it you
know man i don't [ __ ] hide it i was
just like
you guys sit closer than good [ __ ]
white and dream drew
full hands
like jen's like what's he doing jenny's
laughing trying to explain it
she's like well he burns up with the
pond farm
[Laughter]
because i'm like on this cycle now oh
man
it was crazy we we really did have a
good time last night
[ __ ] side effects and [ __ ] it was
just i mean the whole night was just
like [ __ ] hilarious
and then capping it all off with the
karaoke and the woman and the girl
barfing and stuff
yeah so that photograph i just showed
you is because a friend of ours was
walking by with a camera and i said
take a picture of that take a picture of
that and he goes yeah oh yeah demetry
took that picture yeah yeah yeah that's
right
i said take a picture yeah he came down
from the dj movie yeah
um dimitri that's right yeah i was
already drunk i kind of forgot who it
was
drunk pretty quick yeah i was drinking
strawberry vodka like a girl
but um it was good though strawberry
vodka and orange juice it tasted like a
[ __ ] strawberry pop-tart it was
[ __ ] delicious
yeah okay so where was i alright so this
kid
joe is super into monsters like like you
do
and uh he his mom is also into like
monster movies and like hangs out and
watches monster movies with him his
mom's super cool
however his mom is sadly dying of cancer
um so after his mom dies
he ends up having to live with his aunt
and uncle
now his aunt is rad but his
uncle kevin is a total
douche nozzle and he's played by kevin
dillon
and i love that kellen kevin dillon
really like
went for it in this he's just kind of
like over the top he's just like the
biggest [ __ ] tool
in the you know what i mean he's just
like abusive and horrible
and he's um it's funny because like i
said i'm pretty sure that this is a
direct homage to
creepshow the movie like the wraparound
because he definitely says
you know he's picking on the kid for
being into all that horror crap which is
the same thing that
uh tom atkins said in the movie
so this is so it's basically like the
same kind of story where
the kid has you know he has to put up
with this [ __ ] chode
and then he uh has a creep show comic
book
and it's not a voodoo doll but he has
like some other
uh there's some other [ __ ] in there
which uh has to do with his
model monsters and it's basically like a
revenge story
so you know kevin dillon definitely gets
his
comeuppance at the end uh at the hands
of a couple of monsters
which is pretty rad um so yeah so that
one was good
these were both directed by greg
nicotero by the way
but the second one i think was kind of
like the crowning achieve the second one
might be
my favorite of the series so far
the second one is also i think it was
also set in the 70s
um i did i don't think it said
explicitly but it seemed like it was
still set the 70s like just the way
people dressed and
[ __ ] like that and it was set at a pbs
station
and they had um versions of kind of like
all your favorite pbs shows you know
what i mean they had like an antiques
roadshow type of
show they had this kind of like sherry
lewis of lamb chop type of show except
the woman was named uh mrs book berry i
think was her name
and she had this little it was a bear or
a lion or a dog i don't
remember what the puppet was but uh they
had that and also they had
a clearly bob ross dude yeah
doing like a joy of painting show except
it was called the love of painting or
something but he was same
deal where he was like a vietnam vet and
he was like it's real hard but he was
like real chill and he even said happy
little trees i think at some point yeah
which there's truth to that evidently
bob ross was [ __ ]
quite battle-hardened he was doing all
that stuff to chill himself out
that must be where they got the idea for
the story yeah
that's my understanding i don't know if
it's true i had to go back and check it
but in the end
in in this movie they said that he was a
veteran of the ted offensive
which was yeah yeah you were in the rear
[ __ ]
north vietnam north vietnam attacked
[ __ ] troops in a in a um
or attacked the us army in south south
vietnam army
arvind troops is what they were called
they attacked him in the cities so it
was like a
semi-urban warfare that went on it
didn't last for long though but they did
it for the tet festival
and uh my understanding bob ross was
involved in the ted offensively he might
have been i knew it was something like
that he was
helped counter the tet offensive they
all went on
[ __ ] the defensive and [ __ ] a
counter attack to try to get the
offensive out of there
this is one of the only main big battles
in in uh
in vietnam in the vietnam theater yeah
it was almost like a conventional attack
like something the germans would do you
know like an armored assault there were
tanks and [ __ ] involved in it
yeah yeah but yeah so this guy he's not
named bob ross but obviously that's what
he's supposed to be
because like i said he acts just like
him he says things like i said he said
happy little trees
when he does the paint brush like cleans
the brushes beating the devil out
you know he says the same kind of stuff
and he's like pretty much the only nice
person it's like him and the
station manager uh this lady are there
like the only nice people
mrs book barry who has this kids show
with the puppet
she is oh man she's a taunt and
you know what i mean she's just kind of
like because she acts all like
hi kids blah blah blah like on the show
and then like as soon as the camera's
out she's like i gotta go take a [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it was so
[ __ ] funny yeah
and uh so so what ends up happening is
that
ted raymie playing himself um as hey i'm
the famous ted raymie
he is on their antiques roadshow um
you know equivalent i can't remember
what it was called but um
so he comes and he's like hey i found
this thing in my attic and of course
it's like the necronomicon
he's like i was just gonna throw it out
but i thought it was kind of neat and
maybe it was worth something so it was
just like a whole antiques roadshow
thing and uh of course like the host of
antiques roadshow
like opens it starts reading from it and
then everybody starts turning into
demons
and pulling everyone's heads off and
[ __ ] like that so it's just kind of like
this big and of course like the bob ross
dude has to like save the day
um among other people so it's just this
one was super super fun
and it had like all of these kind of
homages to
the original evil dead series you know
what i mean because that's obviously
where they
were going with it so if you like evil
dead you'll probably like really dig
this episode i just i
really really like that they you know
came out of the gate with that like
that's their first episode they have
you know these kind of like throwbacks
to evil dead and then throwbacks to the
original creepshow movie i thought that
was like really cool
but yeah so i guess the next episode is
going to be up on
i think they put them up on thursday
nights or friday is that
the second season yes since i thought so
yes it's weird for a second i thought it
was the third but then i was thinking no
because they had
like i said because the second season
got delayed they did a couple
stand-alone episodes remember they did
that animated one that had like two or
three stories and then they did
like a christmas special one right so
they did like a couple of other ones
kind of lost track yeah i did too
because it's been such a long time
i don't think the first the first season
was pretty was good but i don't think it
was as good as this
yeah i like i said i think these two
stories might be
my favorite now i did love i from the
first season my favorite one from the
first season i think looking back on it
the one that i remember the best
was the one with the dude in the
suitcase yeah that like
where coins came out his mouth or
whatever the [ __ ] yeah i really likes
that one
like the genie one yeah i really liked
that a lot and that's kind of the one
that i remember the best from back then
but so i don't know there's some
competition there but i really really
i mean these two episodes were just
super super fun like these two stories
i think this was i think it was 45
minutes long and it was like two stories
um but yeah i think the second one's a
little bit better because i love like
all that public television stuff
like you know from the 70s and they were
doing like the [ __ ] pledge drive and
all this other kind of
[ __ ] and the dude that was you know the
bob ross dude and yeah
all that kind of stuff and it was like
really really funny and like pretty gory
at the end too because like pretty much
everybody in the [ __ ]
tv station gets killed but you know
they're asking me what what am i gonna
cook for easter
i'm gonna [ __ ] you all up if i'm cooking
for you i'm gonna turn the grill on and
i'm gonna cook all those uh
all those uh georgia sausages all right
oh is that what you're gonna do i'm
going to slice up i'll put that in the
in that spaghetti sauce i have made with
spaghetti
when's the last time we had spaghetti a
long time ago yeah about time to get
some spaghetti i think okay that sounds
good so that's what that's what you're
going to make you're just going to make
spaghetti but with like sausage in it
yeah maybe maybe mastacholi or something
because i have all i have a lot of uh
i have i think it's rotini in there that
i have don't i oh i don't know would you
rather have spaghetti
rather rotini um
i don't have either one's good i don't
have any ricotta or i would do lasagna
oh okay but yeah we have all different
kinds of words
i'm out i'm out of mozzarella anyway
it's gotta be spaghetti okay that'll
work
i haven't had it in a long time yeah
spaghetti probably good actually right
i know well you know i haven't eaten
anything today and it's you know it's
like 3 30.
well because like i said we ate so late
last night we slept so late
yeah we slept late like i think i woke
up at 10 which is like really really
late for me
but i think you slept till noon though
actually i kept waking up in the middle
of the night because i had to
all right let's get that let's shut it
down i'm going to get on that then all
right
yeah tomorrow uh so no easter pookie
bids
no oh man we should have uh we should
have done that got about it
too busy i forgot about it too like i've
been sleeping and then i was like
figuring out the [ __ ] for next week's
shows and whatnot
yeah um maybe we can do that tomorrow
but i think tomorrow we'll do
um we'll do it on the menu we'll do a
food show yeah but we don't know
we haven't decided what food we're gonna
talk about yet do you have any ideas
no no i could talk about food forever
i know you could so it doesn't matter
i'll come up with something yeah we'll
figure something out so we'll do it on
the menu tomorrow and maybe tuesday's
tuesday as well as i don't know we'll
figure something out um but yeah so we
will
see you guys tomorrow happy easter if
you know if you're celebrating it
i might uh go get some candy just
because it's easter
uh but yeah we'll see you guys tomorrow
and talking about some food
so see ya bye